you're not the only person they've tried
to do that with oh it is everybody so
who
are the other people that they've
decided you're going to be the
mouthpiece is like is andrew yang one of
those people like
absolutely andrew yang is 100 somebody
that's been calling the room
that's a per and given the oh universal
credit score and
universal income and that's all davos
group
u.n klaus schwab stuff really mm-hmm
allegedly
a legend oh yeah yeah you've introduced
the button oh yeah we have a button that
doesn't
can't talk about a guy running for
public office god forbid
all right grab it but uh um but okay so
andrew yang a perfect example right he
gets brought in
he runs he has an interesting campaign
maybe he's separate from
these these influencing factors right
these powerful people and then all of a
sudden he gets a job at cnn out of
nowhere
when he gets a job at cnn wasn't he like
a commentator when he gets a job is that
how you know you're like oh okay he's
plugged
in andrew yang i see how he was
unpopular they kept pushing him and then
i know
what the davos group initiative what is
the davos group like
what is that break that down for us if
you go down to the u.n building in new
york a few miles from here
it's all like you won't live in cities
soon you won't have family soon
soon you'll live in communes which is
literally
like living in a tent city or or or or
living permanently in boot camp
and and it's like communism i mean
there's giant science saying
and it shows you will live here and it's
like a concentration camp it shows a
picture of it
and they say you will own nothing you
will have nothing you can pull this up
it's super creepy it's super out of
control but i'm not allowed to reject it
i'm not human
so i love it i love andrew yang i love
bill gates
i love the shots i love it i want to
live in a commune
i love it i love it i love being hit in
the head with bottles well i'm not gonna
do it just yet but anyway
um okay so just build that suspension
we're gonna build something to sit there
um can you thank you very much so okay
so i guess my curiosity is who are these
other figures
so yang is one of them you think he was
brought in they bring you in they sit
you down like they did with you and
they're like listen you're an
influential figure
you people listen to you they care about
what you have to say i'd say it's more
like baseball cards okay
these globalists collect baseball cards
they collect yachts they collect
mistresses they collect
art and then anybody they see that's an
up-and-comer just like hollywood tries
to sign
uh you know a good star music would try
to sign up jimi hendrix i mean
they just go out and talent scout and
try to buy everybody up and everybody
gets the same speech oh you're gonna be
a big star
you're gonna you wanna be on this
crochet you wanna be on this big star
and
you'll be able to influence us once you
join us and work with our larger agenda
you'll come to these meetings and all
the rest of it but i already had family
and people that were
you know involved in some of that and
they already expressed already knew the
story
we already knew what was going on right
okay and then can you tell me any other
people you think
who are also part of this hollywood
people name names
it could be hollywood it could be
politics like just who are the people
that we've looked at and you're like why
the [ __ ] are you famous like do you ever
look at someone go why the
[ __ ] are you famous well that's like the
rock you look at the rock and you go
that guy is super funny he's photogenic
he he's super good looking
we know why he's a movie star exactly
arnold schwarzenegger you know what i
don't
know
but yeah a lot of these people who are
the fakes it's because they are little
corporate mouthpieces
that go out and say what they're
supposed to do and i think somebody like
this like stephen colbert
he was funny as the stephen cooper
character he was really good
yeah whenever the jokes were being
written by jon stewart now or whatever
it was the point is is that now
he's they admit like charles schumer the
senator of new york calls him and says
what should be in his bits
no that's in the news same same thing
with uh
some of the funnier late night guys he
should be really funny you're wondering
why aren't they funny now
they admit in the news that they get
calls from democrat
spokespersons and like senator schumer
goes i'd like you to talk to this guy
he's my cousin he's he's a funny guy and
those guys know that corporately
their job and their contract is pursuant
to a weird new york senator
can you imagine like a senator calls up
oh andrew i kind of like to see this in
your piece you say [ __ ] you man yeah you
imagine like i'm out of
okay senator schumer says i'm supposed
to say this now here's schumer's joke
so this old man can sit there and watch
and go i control that young man
it's all about these guys that got into
power
basically you know maneuvered their way
didn't have what it took
controlling people that's their power
trip so the power trip is finding these
figures that do have talent
and then utilizing that talent to
exalt their opinions and views on the
world absolutely and well
and let them build up and get a
following first so they have the trust
of the people
and then we flip them bingo and the
people that they don't flip
they got a silence yes and that's what
happens with you they tried to do that
with joe
instead we exactly said we just rushed
the whole [ __ ] system
say [ __ ] you we have a whole new
renaissance because all the renaissance
is it's not a utopia it's saying
all the old [ __ ] weird [ __ ] we throw
it out all the old weird shit's like oh
rainbow flags oh look black people
that's not it's all exploiting
gay people and black people there's
nothing to do with rainbow flags and gay
people
they're just literally sitting there
putting that out we need a total
renaissance to overthrow the entire
thing empower everybody well you're
saying
if you're not saying let's get rid of
rainbow flags and black people that's
what it sounded like
you're saying people use mascotting the
rainbow flags get
rid of the the front get ready
i said i really like black people yeah
do what i say i like black people like
what you're a [ __ ] opportunity i i
see what you're saying i see what you're
saying but this is interesting
no no i'm saying they can't don't get
rid of rainbow flags and black people
i'm scared of the people that are using
rainbow flags and black people i'm just
saying stop listening to them
yeah like when some defense contractor
has a rainbow flag you're like dude
that's not you know you're killing
people but you're using this rainbow
flag so we think protection
you think you have good opportunistic no
but it doesn't
listen i don't know if it's 100 true but
it does make perfect sense that
a guy like stephen colbert who was
absolutely hilarious when he was on the
colbert show he was absolutely hilarious
when he was on the daily show
moves to this late night show and is
just not funny because just not
because they give the speech writers
they give the joke writers here's the
talking points make it funny
now we assume here's the thing we assume
as comedians were like oh
being on network tv limits your ability
to be funny
but you're not saying that you're saying
once you're on network tv you're
part of this system that dictates the
opinion of the joke
only starting about 10 years ago because
before they thought
news could manipulate people but people
learned that news was [ __ ]
and so they went okay what do they still
trust they trust comics they trust movie
stars
so comics of movie stars were always
political but they they
fully came in and now they're full
thrust is that